forgot you're a member of Nobel
Committee for physics and you have just
awarded the discovery of the expansion
of the universe which is going faster
and faster what exactly is expanding oh
this is a fantastic discovery what is
expanding is the fabric of space-time
itself so the universe is amounts to the
content of space-time and the whole
thing is expanding so even the universe
in this room like we are receding from
each other well every point in the
universe is receding from every other
point however this room is very small so
the expansion is my nude however if we
look at the galaxy which is some
distance away then the expansion is
measurable and if you look at objects
which are really far away like the
supernovae which are about half way back
to Big Bang then they're really receding
from us at fantastic speeds so how big
is this expansion well the universe has
about doubled in size over the past five
billion years which is since the
beginning of our solar system our solar
system was born about 5,000 five billion
years ago where is this discovery is so
perplexing well before the expansion was
the accelerating expansion was
discovered one believed that the
universe was dominated by matter by
objects like ourselves like the stars
and Suns like planets and a universe
which is dominated by matter will be
expected to slow down due to the pool of
gravity
and so the two groups of researchers set
out to measure this deceleration as it
it's called the slowing down of the
universe and to everyone's amazement and
they wouldn't believe what they saw they
realized that the universe was not
decelerating it was actually
accelerating totally amazing you said
earlier that was like pushing the break
in the car what happens well you push
the break in the car and you expect the
car to slow down and stop eventually but
if you discover that your car instead of
accelerated oh my god something is
happening which is you know not what I
expected and that was the feeling they
got something totally unexpected so
somehow the universe was born for in Big
Bang for 14 billion years ago and then
it was decelerating slowing down the
expansion and then it began somehow to
expand faster and faster when they did
happen well it happened at about the
time when the solar system was born
actually when it depends on the balance
of various components of energy within
the universe and I Shan has taught us
that e equals MC squared so matter a
mass is equivalent to energy and the
balance between buyers forms of energy
between matter between radiation and
other forms of energy is what determines
how the expansion's varies with time and
the bath at the time when the solar
system was born this unknown form of
energy which we called dark energy
started dominating over matting the
component was largest over some and
since then the universe is accelerating
how actually how was the discovery done
how can you see the accelerating
expansion well to see the accelerating
expansion you need two things one is
that you need something which is called
standard candles you need some object in
the universe which you see at very far
distances and this was the supernova
which can be observed at cosmological
distances so you go back to the birth of
the universe many billion years ago and
then you need the cosmological model and
to obtain a cosmological model you need
to rely on Einstein theory of relativity
and on his general theory of relativity
and then comparing the expectation of
this model with what you observe how
much light you see from this distant
supernovae and comparing how much light
you see from the distance supernova with
how much like you see from those nearby
you can deduce if the universe is
slowing down as Einstein with heavy or
that it actually is accelerating so the
groups that are awarded today they
expected actually like I think that the
expansion will decelerate it will go
slower and slower but it didn't well
that that was the expectation they
expect the universe dominated by matter
by the things we can see and believe are
there and in a universe like that
according to Einstein you would expect
universe slowing down the expansion
which started at Big Bang would
eventually slow down and this is not
what they observed now the expansion of
the universe is actually has been known
for almost a century sin 1920s why
didn't they notice that the expansion is
going faster and faster already earlier
well this is a difficult measurement as
we already spoke before the expansion is
only obvious if you go to very large
distances and to go to very large
distances in the universe you need
objects which are visible at very large
distances and hence the supernova so the
proposal to use
for no vivo observation was put forth in
1938 by bother however it turned out
that the super know he were not alike
they were that different kinds of
supernovae and to be able to make a
measurement on the basis of observed
luminosity you need similar super Noli
and it was only nineteen sixty-eight
that one realized that such super know
he existed so knowing that a knob ject
exists it's not the same thing as
finding sufficiently many of them to
make a measurement and so you expect to
see only one or two of these supernova
explosion per thousand years in any
given galaxy so this is a difficult
measurement you need to observe very
many galaxies to be able to make a
statement at all and it was then only
with the development of the CCD imaging
systems that the two groups of
scientists in the 1990s were able to
observe sufficiently many galaxies at a
single time to be able to catch
sufficient in many supernovas and we are
talking about 40 supernovas in one group
and about 16 in the other group to be
able to make a measurement and this is
why it took time it universe is vast
they were competing with each other in
those observations but now they get the
price together how come but they were
actually racing each other but they
discover was so improbable that they
needed each other support for the
community to believe what was observed
the two independent groups making the
same observations were absolutely
necessary
there is one question which is buried
behind those observations and this is a
question about the fate of the universe
what does it mean for answering this
question what what is the final fate of
the universe oh the fate of the universe
depends of course on the expansion and
in a universe which is accelerating will
when the galaxies will eventually move
so far apart that we will not be able to
see any other galaxies than our own we
would expect that galaxies which are
close to our own will be pulled towards
the the Milky Way by gravity but the
galaxies which are far away with will
just disappear out of sight so the
universe will become darker and darker
however we will just see the galaxy
which surrounds us to us at earth the
universe will be as bright as ever it's
a consolation I would say thank you very
much audible part thank you
you